[Applause]
[Music]
in 2017 it'll be 70 years since india
broke off from the british empire and
became an
independent country which is today
actually the largest democracy
in the world in these 70 years india has
managed to implement a political system
with more than
1 000 parties and high female
participation
that is totally unprecedented in such a
poor country
of course we should probably wait before
we pop the champagne because we can't
exactly
say that these 70 years of independence
have gone brilliantly in this gigantic
country of more than 1.2 billion people
poverty equality a terrible caste system
and
many many problems with women's rights
have continued to shake this nation
that and forwards with pakistan which
has become
something of a arch enemy of india
[Music]
but if you really want to know why we
might claim that india can't be proud of
the last 70 years well
we only need to compare this country's
evolution with that of
china see when deng xiaoping launched
his policy to open up china to the world
and changed its economic model back in
the 1980s the sizes of these two
economic giants
china and india they were similar in
2016 however china's gdp it was five
times higher i mean just check out this
graph
[Music]
and not only that these differences
repeat in practically
every statistic social and economic and
how about another example
well while china's illiteracy rate
affects less than four percent of the
population in china almost
one out of every three people can't read
or write
so considering all this we should almost
reach the conclusion that the only good
thing that this country has achieved has
been its democracy
right well wait just a second because it
seems that this poverty and injustice
is beginning to shift
[Music]
more and more experts are betting that
the 21st century will be
above all india's century that is to say
that in the next few decades we'll
witness how this country emerges from
the developing world
to become an economic superpower many
companies such as amazon and apple
are already betting on this
transformation and are paying close
attention
to this huge market they understand that
if expectations are met
in the next few years we could see one
of the biggest business opportunities
in history
[Music]
and it's not just companies the delhi
government's own expectations are so
high that they expect this country's
transformation to be at least as
impressive as that of
china in the coming decades
[Music]
for this reason they want to be prepared
they are contemplating for example
building 250 airports
six new macro ports and creating more
than 150 million
new and accessible homes in the next 10
years alone
[Music]
in other words everything indicates that
we may see india's takeoff which
well that's got to be a good thing right
well do keep one thing in mind and that
is that beijing doesn't like this
they don't like it at all
[Music]
distrust and resentment
china is india's main trading partner
however despite this
chinese authorities look at india's
growing economic political and military
capacity with
a lot of distrust this is because this
is a time when china wants to gain
political influence
and this change in india it doesn't suit
them at all india is perhaps the only
country in asia with enough potential to
offset
china's political power in the region
after all we're talking about what will
soon be the most populated country on
earth and there's even some analysts who
confirm that maybe this has already
happened that india has already
surpassed china in terms of population
size
but it isn't only that because of the
one child policy that affected china for
so many years india's population
has and will have more young people and
less
elderly people which is quite a
significant advantage
given these circumstances it's easy to
understand beijing's distrust of india
don't you agree india has the fastest
growing
economy in the world we hope we're going
to be catching you very soon in terms of
percentage increase i have to tell you
that
we're working on it now don't think that
this feeling only exists in political
offices
not at all in fact this growing rivalry
is actually also reflected on the
streets
consider the following data
according to a survey published in 2016
by the pew research center only
one in four chinese people have a
favorable opinion of
india and in india things are not more
encouraging seven out of
every 10 are worried about beijing's
military drive
and believe that china's economic
influence is hurting them in other words
it seems that both china and india's
populations know that their neighbors
are also their great rivals
in any case curiously it must be said
that despite all of this rivalry
bollywood is actually quite popular in
china this summer we saw how dangal an
indian blockbuster swept the chinese box
office and became
one of the highest grossing films in
china of all time
and well as you might imagine this is
something that the government in beijing
they don't really like that much in
terms of soft power
india has done better than china
although india's economy is not as
developed they have put a huge emphasis
on promoting their culture jiang jin kui
director of the southeast asian research
institute at peking university
well anyway it would be great if all
tensions occurred in let's say such a
peaceful way
but unfortunately that is not the case
[Music]
disputes in himalayas
while everyone was looking at pyongyang
and the north korean nuclear crisis
occupied every front page another
political crisis when it was about to
explode
it happened in the himalayas more than 4
000 metres above sea level in one of the
most remote
places on earth the doklam plateau in
this place between
june and august one of the most serious
political crises between
china and india in the last 55 years
occurred when chinese troops
invaded northern india see on june 8
a squad of chinese border guards and a
construction team entered a territory
that is disputed between
china and the small closed kingdom of
bhutan yes that is bhutan the country
with the highest gross national
happiness
and yes that is something we will
certainly be discussing in a video
someday but
well the fact is that the chinese units
destroyed several bunkers owned by the
bhutan royal army
and they began to build a road
since bhutan's protection has been in
india's hand since the 1940s indian
troops arrived on june the 16th
and blocked the road's construction so
far a pretty typical border conflict
however tensions they didn't dilute they
actually increased
and the discussions between beijing and
new delhi while they became
quite tense chinese state media began to
threaten the indian government with
serious consequences china and india are
dangerously close to military conflict
in the himalayas
now at this point you might be wondering
well why on earth was a land that is
practically frozen for most of the year
given such importance well on the one
hand it seems that xi jinping's
government wanted to test india and
punish them for
well a bunch of things for their
relationship with the dalai lama and
with tibet for their growing ties with
washington for their relations with
pakistan and so on and with regard to
india because china's control in this
area with its military presence and new
road would put china within a stone's
throw of the siliguri corridor
a narrow strip of land considered
strategic because it connects
seven of the states of northeast india
with the rest of the country
this is something you can see well on
this map
and above all beyond tactical issues
there's another important reason the
same reason why china wanted to test
india and you're going to see what i'm
talking about in just a minute
the fact is that finally on august 28th
after many threats and a lot of tension
both sides agreed to withdraw their
troops and return to the starting point
of this entire political muddle
of course years ago both power's rivalry
wasn't as obvious as it is now and of
course
let's not fool ourselves the dot clan
plateau is well
it's the least of it and i'm not just
saying this because of the more than 3
000 kilometers of border that have
territorial disputes between china and
india
there are many many more reasons
[Music]
a national strategy
given the possible emergence of india as
a superpower the chinese government have
adopted a strategy
and that's to surround it and yeah it's
pretty much exactly what it sounds like
in recent years china has tightened its
ties with pakistan in exchange for 60
billion dollars in infrastructure
especially to connect both countries
including a strategic port in gwadar
that
china will operate until at least the
year 2050.
[Music]
on the other hand a chinese government
company has taken control of hambantota
port in sri lanka
a country with which beijing is also
strengthening its political ties
regarding bangladesh
china has become his most important arms
supplier last year they sold them
two submarines and finally there's nepal
which has greatly improved its
relationship with china after a
political conflict in 2015 with new
delhi now well let's have a look at a
map
[Music]
you see india is surrounded
bhutan crisis it was simply nothing more
than a move
in a chess game and this is a chess game
in which china has the economic capacity
and the money to make friends very
easily and of course
the fact that china's military
superiority over india is overwhelming
well that's also very helpful so a
question that might arise after all of
this
is well what's india's bet or rather
what's their realistic response
and well that response it basically
comes in three words and those three
words are
the united states
[Music]
yeah as you heard it in recent years
relations between the united states and
india have become pretty close
see between 2009 and 2016 bilateral
trade has doubled and the sale of
military equipment
from the united states to india has
multiplied by
50. in fact
everything indicates that india is going
to replace their old mig-21 with a
mega contract of newly manufactured
f-16s
200 of them and if this is confirmed
lockheed martin's intention the
manufacturer with pentagon's approval of
course is to transfer
this plane's worldwide production from
texas to india a pretty
unbeatable way to strengthen alliances
don't you think
well now we can better understand not
only china and india's tense
relationship but also for example the
us's new hard strategy towards pakistan
which we discussed in our previous video
about afghanistan
[Music]
[Applause]
and of course all of this starts based
on a premise that india will emulate the
economic success
that china has achieved in recent
decades narendra modi the
popular indian prime minister of whom we
already talked about is
leading many changes but not as many as
the country needs
but that is a discussion we can leave
for another day and now we want to know
do you think
china will succeed in beating india well
please do
leave your comments in the comment
section below and don't forget to
subscribe to our channel for brand new
videos every monday and thursday also do
not forget to check out our friends at
the reconsider media podcast they
provided the vocals in this episode that
were not mine
and well if you look for something else
to watch please do check out my brand
new channel biographics where we do
biographies of notable people from the
past and the present
and as always thank you for watching